the death of legendary designer Karl
Lagerfeld's he passed away today at the
age of 85 a clearly Karl left his mark
on Hollywood I would like to call
Lagerfeld closet the envy of star
fashionistas Karl known for his white
ponytail in those dark glasses brought
high fashion to the masses and to
Hollywood for the past 50 years
everything that has done in 1977 he
became Fendi's creative director but his
takeover of Chanel in a three cent
hemline sky-high and injected youth into
a brand that celebs still love today so
iconic it's so classic but yet it's
still very relevant and hip and edgy so
he's very strong and and doing very
beautiful not only did Carl change
celebs fashion he also changed their
lives helping launch Claudia Schiffer's
career what are we wearing Chanel Chanel
of course today Claudia posted he
transformed me from a shy German girl
into a supermodel he is irreplaceable
from Naomi Campbell thank you for taking
the chance on a 16 year old girl who has
just been a very loyal supportive person
to my career
every journey ends but we go on back in
2012 Brad Pitt was Carl's choice to sell
Chanel number five to women wait a good
idea come from in the middle of a night
in a dream
no till we have to take Lagerfeld leaves
behind a godson Hudson and beloved
Instagram famous cat shupette though
sometimes controversial Karl always had
a strong work ethic and a sense of humor
to go with and just a working class
working with class huh